[Musique]
ce mandat n'est pas encore
officiellement commencé qu'elle suscite
déjà la controverse les appels à la
démission de Amira alghaouabi n'ont fait
que se multiplier toute la semaine en
raison de ses écrits passés sur la loi
21 et sur les sentiments anti-musulman
quel attribut au Québec la première
représentante fédérale à la lutte contre
l'islamophobie peut-elle encore mener à
bien le mandat de 4 ans que lui a confié
le Premier ministre le chef du Bloc
québécois pense que non malgré les
excuses qu'elle a offertes
je veux dire les gens québécois je vous
ai entendus je vous écoute et je
comprends les effets du mémo et je veux
vous rencontrer je veux entendre plus je
veux bien comprendre l'histoire
québécoise
bonjour merci d'être avec nous c'est un
plaisir d'être là et en personne
personne
[Musique]
le premier en tout cas la rencontrer en
personne vous êtes tout de même sorti
delans a fait pas la job pourquoi elle
fait pas la job tel que je pense qu'elle
devrait être faite elle aura peut-être
l'occasion de la faire comme le premier
ministre pense qu'elle doit la faire ce
n'est pas personnel et je voulais
beaucoup enlever la variable personnelle
agressive vindique de réseaux sociaux ça
c'est très bien passé c'est une femme
intelligente c'est une excellente
communicatrice elle a une très très
bonne maîtrise du français mais
de façon assez candide sa connaissance
du Québec est très limitée le fait que
au Québec la notion de laïcité et de
loin antérieure à l'existence même du
mot islamophobie pourrait c'était des
choses passablement nouvelles et cette
ignorance-là du Québec qui s'ajoute à
des propos passés qui sur la forme et
sur le fond le fond c'était des Brigitte
la forme c'était c'était intense et très
injurieux font en sorte qu'elle ne peut
pas se mettre en position de médiatrice
pour faire en sorte que les gens qui se
connaissent mal ou les communautés qui
se connaissent mal se rapprochent elle
est campée dans un rôle hostile aux
valeurs québécoises et à cette
association qui n'est pas acceptable
entre le mot islamophobie et la notion
de laïc mais en même temps ça
méconnaissance du Québec et je suis pas
il connaît probablement pas très bien
l'alberto non plus ouh là la saskatchoa
nous mentoba britannique est-ce que ça
fait pas un peu partie du mandat là je
vais aller sur le terrain je vais aller
découvrir ce qui se passe puis ensuite
je Rev pour faire des recommandations
parce qu'il y a pour guider le
gouvernement fédéral dans le fond dans
ces politiques dans l'application
politique de loi pour s'assurer que on
tient compte du problème de
l'islamophobie beaucoup de choses dans
un premier temps son rôle est très
public donc ce n'est pas qu'un rôle de
conseil elle est apparue et elle a été
utilisée comme emblème par le Premier
ministre qui l'a amené au commémoration
du drame terrible de la mosquée de
Québec première chose deuxième chose
j'attends pas de mon mécanicien qui la
prennent la mécanique après que je lui
ai confié ma voiture mais bien qu'il la
connaissent avant elle ne connaît pas le
Québec et ses potes le Québec comme
l'Alberta ou comme l'île du
Prince-Édouard c'est le Québec en
particulier parce que le Québec est la
seule juridiction présentement à
l'intérieur du Canada qui met de l'avant
la notion de laïcité de l'État avec tous
les préjugés le fait de pointer du doigt
qui a été fait par le grand rayonnement
du Grand Toronto et elle en particulier
au cours des dernières années contre le
Québec est-ce qu'elle aurait pu dire
quoi que ce soit durant votre rencontre
qui aurait changé qui a changé votre
perception
je l'avais dit avant donc c'est pas
nouveau difficilement difficilement il
me semblait incorrect de
demander le départ de quelqu'un sans
même avoir eu une rencontre avec cette
personne-là la responsabilité n'est pas
celle de Madame
elle est celle de Monsieur Trudeau sans
équivoque il a manœuvré sur une base de
politique partisanée intéressée et non
pas dans le sens de lutter contre le
fait exprès
ne connaissant une conséquence connue
peut faire partie de l'intention
monsieur Trudeau ne peut pas ne pas
avoir vérifié les propos intérieurs
avant de placer un candidat dans une
circonscription qu'on a aucune chance de
gagner on vérifie ce que quelqu'un a dit
dans le passé imaginez un poste
mettons présumant que c'est le cas
pourquoi il aurait fait ça
ça m’amène dans une position de procès
d'intention sans démonstration possible
je peux supputer supposer croire et je
le crois que le fait de jouer le Québec
contre certaines fait partie du Canada
les valeurs québécoises contre le
multiculturaliste canadien c'est entre
guillemets politiquement
électoralement parce que on pourrait
penser vous moi que la prochaine
élection à jouera pas au Québec elle va
se jouer dans le Très Grand Toronto la
fronton va se faire là le pouvoir va se
gagner ou se perdre à cet endroit-là et
Dieu aussi que cet enjeu-là et on a une
façon de le démontrer dans le contexte
actuel cet enjeu-là peut faire recette
dans le Grand Toronto parce que prenez
par exemple Pablo Rodriguez qui a
toujours été défendent les pires
positions des libéraux au Québec qui le
dit je trace une ligne je ne suis pas
confortable avec ça monsieur champagne
c'est la même chose et il y a des
ministres du Grand Toronto qui disent on
est très d'accord avec ce qu'elle dit
elle doit être là et Monsieur Trudeau a
tranché à 100% ce sont ces mots en
faveur des députés de Toronto et au
détriment du Sud est-ce que est-ce que
l'idée d'un représentant pour
pour constater sur le terrain ou pour
mener la lutte contre l'islamophobie
c'est une bonne idée
ça aurait pu être une bonne idée il y a
deux conditions qui sont pas remplies
d'abord il est vrai que dans l'actualité
et depuis un certain temps l'enjeu des
relations entre une certaine vision de
la religion musulmane ou de l'islam et
d'autres communautés à travers le pays
particulier c'est plus intense c'est
plus intense cela dit il y a plein
d'autres minorités il y a des minorités
à caractère culturel des minorités
visibles des minorités religieuses des
minorités sexuelles qui sont également
l'objet de discrimination donc ça c'est
un premier problème et le deuxième
problème c'est que parce qu'il a
politisé de façon intéressée et nocive
pour le Québec la fonction elle ne peut
plus exister les Québécois ne feront
plus confiance à cette invention là qui
plutôt que de servir ce que le Comité de
la sécurité publique voulait ou le
Secrétariat à la lutte contre le racisme
voulait il en a fait un instrument
politique à court terme en sachant très
bien que ces propos passés allaient être
incendiaires pour les Québécois qui sont
attachés à leur valeur de laïcité je
vais vous entendre sur les travaux du
Comité des opérations du gouvernement
cette semaine qui s'est penchée sur
toute la question des contrats attribués
au film de consultant externe à celle de
la ferme Mackenzie dont on a beaucoup
parlé pourquoi est-ce que c'est
important d'après vous que le comité se
penche là-dessus c'est important pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord réglons tout
de suite une chose et machiner vous le
dirait ils ne sont pas la firme que le
plus de contrôle il y a plusieurs qui en
ont davantage ce qui distingue qui
disait c'est le mode d'opération le
Modus operadi et la nature des mandats
d'une part Mackenzie ou des gens qui
étaient mais qui disent sont à l'origine
de ce qu'on appelle le centurion financé
par des grandes banques et des grands
milieux financiers qui disait il faut
qu'à la fin du siècle il y a 100
millions de Canadiens qui est 12.5
millions de personnes dans la grande
région de Montréal Toronto on ne sait
plus combien et pour arriver là il faut
que dès 2025 il y a 500 000 personnes
par année qui deviennent immigrants au
Canada c'est une intervention à
caractère politique et pratiquement
idéologique dont Monsieur Barton
l'ancien dirigeant de Mackenzie de dit
nous le français le Québec on n'a pas
tenu compte de ça c'est pas de nos
affaires donc c'est un enjeu important
et le deuxième c'est dans le mode
d'opération le mode d'opération de ce
qu'on appelle c'est pas les contrôles
ouverts et l'équivalence c'est un
contrat où on dit le fameux contrat de
80 de 80 il y en a plusieurs c'est on ne
vous dit pas ce que ça contient ce que
ça doit faire on ne vous dit pas combien
ça va coûter le chiffre qui est inscrit
c'est zéro et ça va finir en 2100
longtemps après notre mort à tous mais
c'est d'une opacité profondément
inacceptable et Monsieur Burton l'ancien
dirigeant de mackenzee admis à ma
demande que lui comme dirigeant
d'entreprise ne signerait pas un tel
contrat s'il était client et pourtant
ils ont fait signer plusieurs contrats
de ce type là et juste un Trudeau a
accepté je vous entends sur l'idée
d'étendre le travail du comité au
travail de toutes les films de
consultants le NPD a déposé une motion
on aimerait ça ils aimeraient ça aller
au-delà de mes kendji qu'en pensez-vous
je pense que ce que les libéraux veulent
et font faire le travail par le NPD
c'est de noyer le poisson mckinzé si on
va rentrer tout le monde sur la table ça
va devenir tellement gros lourd et
complexe qu'on pensera pas au travail
allez savoir tout ce qui se fait avec
toutes les films je suis d'accord
complétons les travaux sur mackenzee
d'abord puis après on élargi relation et
François Blanchette merci un grand
plaisir